have
please you can work it out from four
downwards
Edge so so I'm
pausing Edge
so right so down to three
movements now the pressure gets harder
on each person cuz you shouldn't be sort
of staring at them you're not if you
start using them as a challenge as an
attacker as I said earlier they will
slow you down because you will be stiff
to be free you must be free so Heather's
there but really I want to be
with the dust spin or with the trees or
wherever so here goes
Edge
KNE so the only thing I can do is I can
watch and I'll know if she's went faster
than me that's the only thing you need
to really take into consideration if
they went F if your partner goes faster
than you then you know that somewh
you've got to kick up a gear so you bit
faster than okay so three movements
if you don't get time in the pause to
pull yourself back really tight to know
that you are you have settled then
you're not in control